hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to will your pest of
the baton oops
ignore that it's fine so I've got a
conundrum here for you what if you could
be the person of your dreams the strong
person the weak person the sexy person
the beautiful person the rich person the
YouTuber person a member of team can you
say oh your dreams are need to reach a
little higher anyway you get to be the
person of your dreams but you have to
first survive five years on an island by
yourself which to be perfectly honest
doesn't seem all that bad I get five
years alone to myself to dream up the
ideal person that I could be who would
be exactly the same as I am right now
but three inches taller yeah that's the
person my dreams that's that's what I
see when I go to bed every night I see
myself just three inches taller that's
it that's all I want
I'm perfect in every way as I am now one
number one I only dream of myself and
number two he's just he's just a little
bit taller just a little bit that's all
that's all I ever ever could possibly
want I'll do that cuz I mean if you're
on an island by yourself for five years
I mean I guess you struggled to survive
and all that but yeah I'll do it
oh hey hey come on there we go yeah see
ya see you guys would have push the
button you guys would have pushed it oh
yeah you would have pushed the button
next you get married to whoever you want
but anything you touch burns even earth
well I mean you can technically marry
whoever you want they just have to agree
to it like it's but I mean like
everything you touch birds and are we
talking like are we talking like burns
as in like an itch or a rash are we
talking like burns as in is on fire
because there's a distinct difference
whether you're spreading the most
widespread and horrific STD in history
or you're burning everything if you like
if you're standing on your something
that burns your shoes everything
touching your body is always on fire
you're just gonna die you're just gonna
die or be very uncomfortable those are
the two options you and everything
around you is either gonna die or be
uncomfortable yeah I'm not gonna press
up on them I'm really not I don't want
to do that it doesn't seem like this it
doesn't seem like there's a good to that
all right you can get whatever you want
when you want but you have to kill
somebody for it in the following one a
minute now it's not specifying wait hang
on this this isn't this isn't any
different from real life you can get
whatever you want
if you kill people for it anyway like I
mean I'm not saying it's a good thing
it's not a good thing but I mean if you
want to be technical about this if you
see somebody with something that you
want technically you could take it from
them by killing them which is not a good
solution and he doesn't say that you
wouldn't be punished for killing
somebody for something I want world
peace bang just ended world peace now
dead nice oh that didn't work out very
well
bang bang bang I want to end hunger see
he's not hungry anymore I'm still not
gonna press that button all the
grandiose things aside I guess I guess
if it's not going for the thing things
but you what if like what if you do you
know I'm just gonna go no we can get
there without killing people I'd like to
think let's go with no on that one Wow
Wow it's a lot of murders that's a lot
of murder that's a lot of greedy
murderers that's a lot of a lot of
murderers out there you can live for as
long as you want but you can never have
children does that count
adoption now that's interesting they're
saying you you can never have children
but what about adoption what about
cloning yourself get an infinite number
of yourselves it can live for as long as
you want that's my dream
Hey I'm the guy that dreams of myself
but just a little bit taller
well I can't happy the guy that dreams
of cloning himself and I living for if
the entire population is nothing but me
me it's like that one episode of Doctor
Who
it's just nothing but me see I can see
yeah I'll press that button why not
let's do it let's do it all right well
apparently people don't want kids
all right you will receive ten million
dollars but you will be erased from
everyone's memory God win-win if ever
there was one
what a win-win everybody can forget
about me instantly and I get 10 million
dollars hell yeah oh yeah I mean you can
remind if it's like a family thing you
just go up to your family be like I'm at
I'm your long-lost son here see all
these pictures of me and them see those
this me believe me all right whatever
see around can we be friends like
there's no losing that oh come on you
big baby
53 percent didn't press that button good
god
good god that's an amazing button
wouldn't you guys press that button if
you could just like I know our family
and all that aside but still you start
over it's new game+
for life you just hit the button you got
ten million smackeroos owes you put that
in an investment you spend you spend
like five hundred thousand on getting a
house you put the rest in in your
savings investments put into like stocks
and bonds and all that
[ __ ] dividend for life good yeah anyway
you want a trip to anywhere you wish to
go around the world but you cannot touch
or even look at the gender you are
attracted to even look what am i great
hang on you win a trip to anywhere you
wish to go around the world you cannot
touch or even look at the gender you are
attracted to you mean like what are they
just gonna be like moving shadows in
front of my eyes I kind of have to go
into public like earth my head just
gonna automatically snap away from any
person to wrap me that's the gender that
I'm attracted to so this is like oh god
is that a lady over there god damn it I
hate this curse but goddamn the scenery
is beautiful I mean if you're really
going there for the scenery I guess is
brute and I say guys taking the the
grandeur but if that is that forever I
mean I could just add you know that's
the thing about my life I always forget
I can at any moment go wherever I want
to in the world I just happened to be
chained to my computer desk and now I'm
depressed that's sad
I'm not gonna do that I don't want to
break my neck you're the best at every
possible skill but you're not allowed to
show anyone any skill you have
you know that's fine I mean I
technically I guess I live my life
showcasing my skills on video but hey if
I was the best in the world that someone
at something I don't necessarily need to
show anybody that I am the best at
something that's it I'm the best arts
'men I'm the best craftsman my art will
never be shown to anybody but also like
technologic God actually no that's not
good you're not allowed to show anyone
wait it says show anyone that doesn't
mean that they can't see it I'm not
showing them but they can see like the
results of my work not necessarily me
performing something but if I'm working
on something it's not like it turns to
ash when someone sees it right if I just
happen to lay it out in the middle of
nowhere if I'm just like if I put a
block of marble in the middle like Times
Square and I just start chipping away at
it I'm like an incredible art ceman but
it's just like no one can see it's like
a moving shadow like why is that guy
just hammering at air he's threatening
somebody's gardening with a hammer and
chisel and then I'm dead okay yeah I'll
go for it why not you have wonderful top
human skills what's a top human give me
an idea of what a top what is a top
human here another top human like a
human that's you know there's a bottom
human and there's a top human is that
what we're talking about here genius
super-strong etc but nothing interesting
will ever happen
define interesting what do you mean
interesting what does that even mean how
do you stop life from being interesting
I mean my life is boring as [ __ ] anyway
so this isn't really gonna change
anything so what does that mean
like I said earlier I could go anywhere
in the world but don't mmm yeah well
press it sure why not you can teleport
to anyone you want to just by thinking
about them but you will teleport just by
thinking about them
oh oh oh god oh god oh god so you
automatically if you think of anybody if
I think of like anybody in the world kim
jeong-hoon boom I'm at I'm right by his
side that's weird
and you just like public if you just
like think of random people what if I'm
looking what if I'm doing like a panel
or something I'm looking at this crowd
of people at am i I'm thinking of you
boink I'm over in the audience I'm
thinking yeah boink
like that doesn't what if I think of an
alien what if I just so happen to think
of an alien and that just so happens to
be an actual alien somewhere in the
universe and boy I'm over there it's
like hey hey guys all right thinking of
my mom
all right back my mom girlfriend boink
over there all right well this is weird
I think I'd like I think I would die
from the shock I'm not gonna do that you
don't have any control over it
no whatever you can become immortal and
can travel through time but you can only
go forward in time it would be
impossible to return to your own time
since you can't go backwards in time
[Music]
fascinating okay I'll leave you guys
with that one you're immortal and can
travel through time which means that you
can only go forward or you could just
live your life and be immortal I mean I
guess if you were bored of a time zone
and you were like I need a fresh start
I'm out of there [ __ ] and then you
just go forward man that'd be that'd be
terrible I have a feeling that would be
horrible like horrible horrible but I
would let you guys decide what that is
let me know what you think down the
comments below thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]